GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
MARCH TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
TWO HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. WILL BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE BECAUSE A
QUORUM IS NOT PRESENT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ARE MONITORING
THIS HEARING PLEASE COME TO ROOM
FOUR FOUR FOUR. SO THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AGAIN OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
MONITORING THIS HEARING PLEASE
COME TO ROOM FOR FORCE THAT WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. DO THE
COVERT PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WITH MODIFIED COMMITTEE
PROCEDURES FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PHYSICALLY PRESENT AT
TODAY'S HEARING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IS REQUIRED IN THE
AUDIENCE. OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
ISN'T. AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
AS POSSIBLE WITHIN OUR TIME
LIMITS WE WILL NOT TOLERATE KIND
CONDUCT OF THIS COMMITTEE'S
PROCEEDINGS VIOLATIONS TO THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT. THE
COMMITTEE HAS FOR BILLS ON ITS
AGENDA TODAY. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMITTEES ABLE TO
COMPLETE ITS BUSINESS AND A LOT
OF TIME WE ARE LIMITING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AS FOLLOWS. FOR EACH
BILL THERE WILL BE A MAXIMUM OF
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WITH
UNLIMITED TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS. AFTER WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES. THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE A TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EACH BILL. STARTING WITH MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CORE HERE IN THIS
ROOM. OTHER WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT. AND THE POSITION ON
THE BILL ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
WILL BE RULED OUT OF ORDER. IF
YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
PORT ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
THE WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL
BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD. FOR THE BILL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING. THIS HEARING
REMOTELY AND WHO WISH TO CALL IN
TO REGISTER THEIR POSITION TO
CALL THE NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING. IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
SEVEN. AGAIN THE NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE NINE TWO.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS YOUR TV OR
COMPUTER SCREEN IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE. BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH A
MODERATE OF PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE DIRECTLY
AT NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWENTY NINETY FOUR AGAIN
916-319-2090 FOUR AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO NEED.
HOME BUSINESS TO ONE PERSON IN
THE COMPUTER. MADAM CAN YOU CALL
THE ROLL. BRIAN THE RIGHT HERE
SAY ARE TELL SEYARTO HE BENNETT
BENNETT HE LOW. MAY MAY HERE
MAILLET. BLANCA RUBIO. WE HAVE A
QUORUM IT'S- BEAUTIFUL TO MAKE
IT THIS MORNING HELLO. AS A
FIRST OUT OF BUSINESS LET'S TAKE
OF THE COMMITTEES CAN CALENDAR
THERE'S ONE BILL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS BILLS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AS
SPECIFIED IN COMMON NUMBER THREE
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK MOVED BY SOMEONE INVENTED
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ON
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO CONSENT
CALENDAR BRIAN HI BRIAN I SAY
OUR TONIGHT SEYARTO. BENNETT
SENATE I LOVE. MAYES MAYES I
MULLIN. WELCOME BLANCA RUBIO ARE
HI. THANK YOU THE FIRST ITEM ON
THE AGENDA IS AB TWENTY THIRTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. GOOD MORNING.
PART OF THE ON TIME CAUCUS WOULD
LOVE TO SEE. WHEN YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THIRTY WILL PUT VOTERS
FIRST BY REMOVING THE INHERENT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WHEN BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ARE INVOLVED IN
DECISIONS AND REDRAWING
POLITICAL DISTRICT LINES. AB
TWENTY THIRTY WILL ESTABLISH THE
COUNTY OF FRESNO CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COME TO DRAW DISK
BOUNDARIES FOR THE FOR COUNTY OF
SUPERVISORS. GERRYMANDERING
ALLOWS ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
TO CHOOSE THE VOTERS IN THEIR
DISTRICTS RATHER THAN ALLOWING
VOTERS TO ELECT THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES IN A FAIR AND
LAWFUL. XIN THE PRACTICE OF
GERRYMANDERING HAS
DISENFRANCHISED UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND DILUTED THEIR VOTING POWER.
MAPS WHICH WERE DRAWN BY LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUPS WHICH TOOK INTO
ACCOUNT THE GROWING DEMOGRAPHICS
OF LATINO COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS
REFLECTED BY THE CENSUS WAS
STRUCK DOWN BY THE FRESNO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. THE
DISTRICT MAP WHICH WAS ADOPTED
BY THE FRESNO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WAS MET WITH
WIDESPREAD LOCAL OPPOSITION. THE
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION WILL PUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF DRAWING
POLITICAL MAPS IN THE HANDS OF
AN INDEPENDENT GROUP OF FRESNO
COUNTY VOTERS ENSURING THAT THE
VOICES IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
HEARD. I WILL HAVE TO WITNESSES
HERE FOR AB TWENTY THIRTY. FIRST
WE WILL HAVE TO LOTUS WORKED OUT
WHO'S REPRESENTING THE HUERTA
FOUNDATION AND NEXT WE WILL HAVE
DORA ROSE WHO WILL BE
REPRESENTING THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
SO ARAMBULA WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL BOTH BY
PHONE. THE FIRST WITNESSES
MENTIONED IS DELORES WORKED WITH
THE DIVORCE WHERE THE FOUNDATION
IS WORTH THE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THAT YET THIS.
CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT THE RIGHT
NOW. IN THE WORLD WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DEMOCRACY. ABOUT PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO CHOOSE THEIR
LEADERS MUST BE ABLE TO
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE. OTHER
PEOPLE ARE BEING MURDERED-
BECAUSE THE- THE BEST ONE TO
TAKE OVER THEIR COUNTRY. AND
WANT TO REPRESENT THEM. WHAT WE
HAVE HERE IS SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR OF COURSE ON A DIFFERENT
SCALE. THAT PEOPLE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO CHOOSE THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES. BUT THE WAYS
THAT THE BIRDS TO PROVIDE
DECLINED BY THIRTY ONE
UNFORTUNATELY- THAT IS A DOES
NOT HAVE THE DESIRED. BUT PEOPLE
TEND TO SEVEN BUT- OF PROBABLY
KNOWS THE IN THE COMMITTEE. OF
BURKE A CLIENT OF MAPS. PUT THAT
THIS LEVEL. WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY
TO THE- COMMITTEE. ANTICIPATED
PLEASE PLEASE GIVE US A OF THE-
TO OUR PREP. AT PUTS THE LEVEL
BECAUSE THE VERY IMPORTANT ROLE
BECAUSE THERE THE ONES THAT. THE
BONTA COME LOOK UP THE STATE
GOVERNMENT IS HAVE SEEN AND THE
BOOK UNCLE THAT. SO AT THIS IS A
REALLY. I WOULD LIKE PAY NOTHER
TAX BUT AMONG FEE M. COMMITTEE
PROTECT THE- I PUT ON THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RYAN MEMBERS I'M SORRY I CAN'T
BE WITH YOU PERSONALLY TODAY AND
I'M VERY HONORED TO BE ON THE
SAME PODIUM SO TO SPEAK WITH
WITH. THIS CHARACTER. I'M
DAUGHTER ROSE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK YOU KNOW
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
GERRYMANDERING SIMPLY HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO PLACE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AT ANY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT. RIGHT UNDERMINE
THEIR POLITICAL SYSTEMS CORE
IDEALS. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL REDISTRICTING
CALIFORNIA'S AHEAD OF THE CURVE
IN REJECTING GERRYMANDERING. OUR
STATE INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
PROCESS WHICH PROHIBITS
INCUMBENTS WITH ELECTORAL SELF
INTEREST IN DRAWING DISTRICT
LINES IS CONSIDERED THE NATIONAL
GOLD STANDARD WE'RE DOING A
REALLY GOOD JOB THERE. AB TWENTY
THIRTY EXTEND THAT PRACTICE
DIFFERENCE NO COUNTY. SO LIKE
THE STATE COMMISSION THE BILL
REQUIRES COMMISSIONERS TO MEET
STRICT ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE PROHIBITS REACHING
CANDIDATES AND LOBBYISTS FROM
SERVING ON THE COMMISSION. IT
CREATES A RANDOM SELECTION
PROCESS TO ENSURE THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE NOT BEHOLDEN
TO ANY ELECTED OFFICIAL. IT
REQUIRED THE COUNTY TO TAKE A
VERY. STEPS TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMISSION REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF THE COMMUNITY SUPER
IMPORTANT. AND THE BILL BELIEVES
VERY ROBUST MEANINGFUL ELEMENTS. OF PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. BY
ENSURE THAT THE ACT TRANSFER.
AND ALSO MOST HEARING BEFORE NO
ADOPTION IT ALSO IS ALSO. A
QUITE. EXPLICITLY PARTISAN PRONE
JOE MANDER WHICH NEEDS. R. IF.
IMPORTANT IN FRESNO COUNTY WHERE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS NETWORKS ARE
POINTED OUT WAS LARGELY
DISREGARDED IN THE REGION
REDISTRICTING PROCESS AND THE
RESULTING MAP. WHICH IS SHIFTED
VERY LITTLE IN DECADES DOESN'T
COME CLOSE TO REFLECTING VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
COUNTY'S DEMOGRAPHICS SO. THE
RESULT IS REALLY ONE THAT. WE
SHOULD ALL OF CORK RIGHT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND FRESNO
COUNTY REMAIN. UNDERREPRESENTED
IN COUNTY GOVERNMENT THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
URGES AN AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
THIRTY TO BRING INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING THE FRESNO COUNTY
AND TO ENSURE THAT ITS
GOVERNMENT TRULY REPRESENTS THE
INTERESTS OF. ALL ITS RESIDENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS ROSE.
NINE WE DON'T HAVE ANY PRIME
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. SO WE'LL MOVE AHEAD ON
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IN
THE ROOM AND ON THE PHONES AS A
REMINDER THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME.
FOR DIGITAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE LIMITED
TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL WILL STAR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO.
PROVIDE THEIR POSITION WHEN AB
TWENTY THIRTY. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING. PAUL YOUR CHART OR
INTENTIONAL JOURNALING ON BEHALF
OF THE FRESNO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE INCLUDING A LOT OF THE
COUNTIES POINTS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. IS ONE PARAGRAPH THAT
ISN'T INCLUDED. THE BORDER LIKE
ME TO READ INTO THE RECORD. THE
FINAL SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICT
BOUNDARY MAP ADOPTED BY FRESNO
COUNTY. RETAINS THREE
EFFECTIVELY TINO CITIZEN VOTING
AGE POPULATION. MAJORITY
MINORITY DISTRICTS. SIMILAR TO
THE THREE PROPOSED MAPS
SUBMITTED. BY VARIOUS LOCAL
GROUPS. AND HAS A POPULATION
DEVIATION OF ONE POINT FOUR
EIGHT PERCENT. IN ADDITION THE
ADOPTED SUPERMAJORITY DISTRICT
BOUNDARY MAP. COMPLIES WITH THE
FEDERAL VOTING RIGHTS ACT. THE
U. S. IN CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONS. IS CONTIGUOUS AND
TO THE EXTENT PRACTICABLE KEEPS
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST CITIES
AND CENSUS DURIN DESIGNATED
PLACES. UNDIVIDED THE MAP ALSO
HAS EASILY IDENTIFIABLE
BOUNDARIES. EXTENT PRACTICABLE.
DOUBLE I HATE THAT WORD. KEEPS
EASY. EACH SUPERVISORIAL
DISTRICT BOUNDARY COMPACT AND IT
DOES NOT FAVOR OR DISCRIMINATE.
AGAINST POLITICAL PARTY.
PRESSRELEASE WRIST. REQUEST A NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
WE'LL TAKE THAT AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON AB
TWENTY THIRTY MODERATED WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF AB TWENTY THIRD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO- EXPRESS STOP
OPPOSITION OR- APPROVAL GO AHEAD
HIT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER I
FIND IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. IN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
ONE MOMENT MISTER SURE WE HAVE A
COUPLE QUEUEING UP. YOU ARE
TAKING- BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION RIGHT CORRECT. OKAY
THANK YOU MUCH AND WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH WHITE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD- THIS IS
SANTIAGO WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
VOTERS CALLING SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY FOR ANYBODY
ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME AS ELIANA
HONEY CUT AND WITH BECAUSE THAT
IS WHAT THE FOUNDATION AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THIRTY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW EITHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. NINE JUST
CONFIRMING MODERATOR THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE COMPLETE- IN THE
QUEUE LOOKING TO PROVIDE THE
POSITION ON AB TWENTY THIRD.
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. EXCUSE ME ONE
IS JUST QUEUING UP NOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN THAT WHAT I
WOULD. OKAY ONE MOMENT THERE
WITH AN OPERATOR.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO. THEY'RE
STILL WITH THE OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE AND LET'S HAVE A
QUESTION WITH THIS ONE SECOND.
FROM THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MISTER CHAIR OUT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING- CHAIR MEMBERS
ADDED THREE FURTHER LATE CALLING
BUT THIS IS JENNIFER MEDLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
BONTA EXPRESSED HER SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY TWENTY THIRTY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MODERATED IS SECOND
INTERLUDE EVERYBODY IN THE QUEUE
. YES SIR THANK YOU ALL RIGHT AS
A MEMBER OF AN IRREGULAR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANTED TO
THE CHAIR BRIAN AND THIS ONE TO
COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR OF THE
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS IN THERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMMISSION IS
MADE UP OF AN IMPARTIAL GROUP OF
CITIZENS IS ABOUT A STERILE
WHICH YOU CAN GET. AND THAT SO
MIKE. ALL THE- SURE IMPARTIALITY
ANNA HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
COMMISSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISPRINT JUST WEST OF I'M TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY JUST BECAUSE
IN FACT YOU ARE A REPRESENT A
FROM FRESNO I'M JUST GONNA TRUST
THAT THIS IS NOT A LOCAL ISSUE
BUT I HAVE SOME DEEP CONCERNS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO SHARE-
SHARE THEM- I'M A LITTLE KID
THIS ONLY APPLIES FRESNO COUNTY-
IF IT'S A POLICY THAT'S A GOOD
POLICY- THAT IT SHOULD APPLY TO
EVERY CAN OF COFFEE COUNTIES IN
IN THE STATE. COUNTY CHARTER CAN
. I'M AT SORT OF STEP BY STEP WE
ARE BEGINNING TAKE MORE MORE
POWER AWAY FROM A CHARTER
COUNTIES IN MAKING LOOK MUCH
MORE LIKE GENERAL LAW COUNTIES.
WITH THERE BEING A PURPOSE FOR
THEM TO BE A TO BE TO BE CHARTER
COUNTIES- AND THEN JUST MAYBE
THE QUESTION IS WHY DOES THIS
ONLY APPLY TO FRESNO COUNTY AND
WHY AREN'T WE KNOW THAT THERE'S-
SAM YOU KNOW COUNTY. ASSEMBLY ST
OKAY. A COUPLE OF. DAYS AS WELL
AS- BRITISCHEN COMMITTEE ONE
APPLY THIS STATE- INSTEAD OF.JUST JUST TO THE COUNTIES ARE
SOME SPECIFIC INSTANCE OF. OF
ABUSE IN IN FRESNO THAT YOU'RE
ADDRESSING WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
CONCERN. I I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THE BILL THAT WOULD COVER THIS
FOR ALL COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I BELIEVE THAT BILL HAS
GOTTEN. TO THE GOVERNOR AND DID
NOT GET HIS SIGNATURE. AND SO
UNTIL THAT TIME I BELIEVE WE
HAVE TO GO HELLO. COUNTY IN TWO
WE CAN- CHAU A CRITICAL MASS OF
CAPIZ THAT WOULD LEAD TOWARDS US
TO ASSESS THE STATE. BUT I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT OVERALL LIFE I
THINK ALL COUNTY SHOULD REMOVE
JERRY MAN. AND THERE'S JUST AN
INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
HERE. THAT BELIEVE FOR DROPPING
TO AN ACID. IT'S NOT. SB DOESN'T
COUNTY BY WHAT HAVE IN PRESS
COUNTY WAS AGREE. THIS LAST
CYCLE WHERE THEY WERE NOT.
HEARING AND LISTENING TO A
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO ADDRESS WITH MY BILL
BUT HE EAGERLY ANTICIPATES THE
BILL THAT WOULD. DO THIS FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. THE SEATTLE I SHARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BACK. HAS ON THIS
HAS SOME OF IT IS THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF SINGLING
OUT ONE JURISDICTION FOR THE
STATE TO APPLY THEIR POWER OVER
AND- YOU KNOW YOU A FRESNO I
THINK- IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
HISTORY- DATE FRESNO COUNTY IS
ACTUALLY DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB
OF WITH THEIR REDISTRICTING AS
IT IS. AND IT. RENDERING IS
CONCERNED I DON'T THINK THAT
DISAPPEARS WITH A CITIZEN
COMMISSION- HE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENED TO SOME OF OUR
DISTRICTS IN THIS LAST. THIS
LAST GO ROUND- THERE'S SOME
PRETTY INTERESTING BOUNDARIES
SO- GIVEN. THAT AT LOOKING AT
FRESNO I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE
GOING TO THAT PICK ON FRESNO.
AND ERODING THAT LOCAL CONTROL
FOR THOSE PEOPLE IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO DO THAT THEN THEY SHOULD
GET A GET A REFERENDUM AND MAKE
THAT MOVE IF ENOUGH OF THEM
SUPPORT THAT AND THAT WILL
HAPPEN. IN FRESNO COUNTY- BUT
LACKING THAT A I KIND OF I FEEL
LIKE THERE'S TOO MUCH STATE OVER
REACH AND A LOT OF OUR LOCAL
ISSUES. AND I THINK- YOU KNOW
GIVEN THAT AND A OF SAME- AT MY
REPERTOIRE THE REPRESENT FROM
THE DESERT HAS SAID- YOU KNOW I
REALLY KIND OF STRUGGLE WITH
THESE. THESE AND OTHERS LIKE IT
AND I WILL PROBABLY REMAIN
CONSISTENT IN MY VOTING- AS I
DID WITH THE OTHER COUNTY THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO READ THE COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
. WITH THAT AS A MEMBER RANDY
LEE MICHAELS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I HAVE THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
OF REPRESENTING HALF OF FRESNO
COUNTY IT REPRESENTING THE HALF
THAT- HOLDS MOST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WE
OFTENTIMES DON'T FEEL LIKE OUR
VOICES HEARD I BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL GIVE US HOPE AND OPTIMISM
THAT DEMOCRACY IS ALIVE AND
FRESNO COUNTY I'M GLAD TO STAND
WITH PEOPLE LIKE THE LOTUS WORK
DONE DOOR OF ROSE. BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S HOW WE WILL STAND
WITH THE PEOPLE OF COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE I WOULD ASK IS
RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE VOTE
HERE TODAY. ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL BILL
BACK MOTION BY SOME MEMBER LOW
AND SECOND BY. SUMER BENNETT-
THIS BILL HAS PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS ONLY ABOUT TWENTY
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT BRIAN. BRIAN
I SEYARTO SEYARTO NO BAN IT.
SENATE I LOW. LO I NEED MAYES
MULLIN WANT TO REVEAL BLANCA
RUBIO BY. THE CONSTRUCTOR FIVE
ONE THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU. THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY GOOD TIMING. PRECIADO A
NICE SHOES A WAR FOR YOU. BY
GETTING THINGS DONE SHOES YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL HI THANK
YOU SIR ALL RIGHT. IF YOU COULD
GIVE. ALL MAKE THE SHORT THAT I
THINK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
STAFF FOR EFFORTS ON THIS BILL-
THIS IS A GREAT BILL AND I'M
REALLY EXCITED WHERE WE ENDED UP
AT HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL VOTING LOCATIONS TO
CALIFORNIA VOTERS BY AUTHORIZED
BY AUTHORIZING COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO HAVE THE OPTION OF
UTILIZING VENUES THAT HAVE BARS
OR SELL ALCOHOL TO SERVE AS
VOTING LOCATIONS. THIS WOULD
MAKE IT THE EXEMPTION MADE ABOUT
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL ELECTIONS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE I RECALL
ELECTIONS A PERMANENT. FOR
FUTURE- ELECTIONS EACH YEAR
COUNTY. ELECTION OFFICIALS
SEARCH. FOR APPROPRIATE
LOCATIONS FURTHER VOTERS. AND
LOCATIONS LIKE BARS AND
RESTAURANTS ARE. A LAST RESORT
FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS BECAUSE-
THEIR DISRUPTIVE TO VOTERS. THE
GOAL IS TO. HAVE AN ACCESSIBLE
QUITE MONNING VIOLENT FOR ALL
VOTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
ONE PRIMARY WITH US ON THIS
BILLS PARTICIPATING BY PHONE
RYAN ROCK YES THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES RUN AROUND GO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS MISTER
ROCKLEY OF TWO MINUTES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AT YOUR RYAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SORRY I CAN'T BE THERE IN PERSON
I AM RYAN ROCCO PLASTER COUNTY
CLERK RECORDER REGISTERED VOTERS
AND CO CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN I LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FLOOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIRIMPORTANT WORK
ON THIS BILL- DURING THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION FOR ALL OF
LAST YEAR INCLUDING. THE
SEPTEMBER GUBERNATORIAL RECALL
ELECTION. COUNTIES WERE ALLOWED
BY YOUR LEGISLATURE THE
TEMPORARY ABOUT THE USE
COMMUNITY CENTERS VETERANS HALLS
BANQUET ROOMS AND LODGES.
LOCATIONS WHERE WE HAVE AVOID
APPROACHING IN THE PAST BECAUSE
THEY WERE ALSO PLACES WHERE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES WERE SOLD.
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN WOULD
MAKE THIS TEMPORARY CHANGE
PERMANENT ALLOWING COUNTIES TO
CONTINUE USING THE APPLICATION'S
GOING FORWARD. FOR THE COUNTIES
THAT WERE ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
TEMPORARY LIFTING OF THE
RESTRICTIONS THEY FOUND THAT
THEY WERE BETTER ABLE TO HELP
THEIR HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WHERE POLLING PLACE
FACILITIES OPTIONS WERE REALLY
LIMITED. IT'S SURPRISING TO
THINK IN THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY BECOMING
HARDER AND NOT EASIER FOR
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO FIND.
SUITABLE POLLING PLACES ARE BOTH
CENTERS FOR THEIR VOTERS.
HOWEVER SADLY IT IS SCHOOLS ARE
LESS INCLINED TO SERVICE POINT
PLACES BECAUSE OF THE SECURITY
CONCERNS. THAT FROM ALL THE
STRANGERS ON CAMPUS CHURCHES ARE
REFUSING TO OPEN UP TO US TO
VOTE CENTERS IN RECORD NUMBERS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH. THE POLARIZING
POLITICAL CLIMATEOF THE DAY
SENIOR CENTER TO PAYING NO
BECAUSE OF OUTSIDERS BRINGING
AND GERMS ENDANGERING THE HEALTH
OF THEIR KIDS THAT COMMUNITIES.
BUT IMPROPER VOTING AT SEVERAL
LOCATIONS THAT THE TICKET
PARTICULARLY. BETTER STRAIGHT
ACT COUNTY. WHO MUST HAVE LARGER
REGIONAL FACILITIES OPEN FOR
FOUR OR ELEVEN AROUND. HAVING
HOLDEN WATCHES AVAILABLE AS VOTE
CENTER SITES HAS BEEN THE
PERFECT ALTERNATIVE TO THOSE
FACILITIES ARE NOW TELLING US.
NO WE'RE NOT AVAILABLE TO YOU.
CAN YOU TO GO THROUGH AN
EXTENSIVE CHECKLIST OF. PARKING
ACCESSIBILITY PROXIMITY TO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. ADA
COMPLIANT AND MORE IN ORDER TO
PICK THE RIGHT FACILITY FOR
COMMUNITY. AT THE POLLING PLACE
OR VOTE CENTER. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVEN WILL ALLOW IT TO CONTINUE
TO USE SOME FACILITIES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES HAVE ENJOYED USING
FOR. THE LAST TWO MAJOR
ELECTIONS AND SOME SPECIAL
ELECTIONS. NOW ESPECIALLY THE
TIME WE'RE REFINING REALLY
FACILITIES IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY MORE DIFFICULT. WE
ARE AWARE OF THE CONCERNS BY
FORTH BY. JEFF AND THERE ARE.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH OUR
ORG. HAD A MEETING ON. WHICH
FEEL IS PER. AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO FURTHER MEETINGS TO FIND MORE
COMMON GROUND LOOKING FORWARD
THANK YOU AND WE- RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST HER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
WAS WRONG WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL WE HAVE
ONE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES CARSON BENOWITZ
FREDERICKS WITH ALCOHOL JUSTIN.
JUSTICE MR BENOWITZ FREDERICKS
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AFTER
HEARING US OUT. AGAIN YEAH MY
NAME IS CARSON BENOWITZ
FREDERICKS AND THE RESEARCH
DIRECTOR AT APPLE JUSTICE SANDRA
FELL. ARE WE DO OPPOSE THIS BILL
BUT WE DO. WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE AUTHORS- AND
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL FOR
REACHING OUT TO US AND SITTING
DOWN HAVING A HAVING A
DISCUSSION- OUR PRIMARY. RIGHT
NOW IS THAT- BARS ARE REALLY NOT
NEUTRAL LOCATIONS- AND THERE IS.
A CONCERN THAT ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
RECOVERY OR PEOPLE WITH. ALCOHOL
RELATED TRAUMA IT'S- PROXIMITY
TO A- BAR PER SE IS. ESSENTIALLY
DIFFERENT FRANCHISING IT REALLY
DISCOURAGES THEM FROM USING THAT
LOCATION AND THEN YOU KNOW.
ARGUABLY COULD RISK RELAPSE. ARE
THERE ARE OTHER. GROUPS YOU
MIGHT BE SOMEHOW- ENJOINED FROM.
BEING IN A BAR- BUT NONETHELESS
HAVE THE VOTE WHO WOULD BE- ALSO
BLOCKED OUT THROUGH THIS- SO
REALLY THAT IS ASSEMBLY ISSUES
OF THE BILL'S CHANGES ARE VERY
BROAD- DO NOT HAVE ANY
PROVISIONS. DO NOT MANDATE ANY
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD ADAPT TO
THESE CHALLENGES- AGAIN FOR
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE IMPACTED BY
THAT CLOSE PROXIMITY TO OUR
PRESENCE IN. A BAR- YEAH WE HAVE
WE DO WE DO RESPECT THAT YOU
KNOW THE- THE CLERKS ARE-
BEARING THESE PROBLEMS IN MIND-
WHEN THEY DO CHOOSE A LOCATION-
BUT BUT UNLESS YOU LIKE TO SEE
LANGUAGE THAT- BRITAX. GROUPS.
AND YET THERE IS MORE MORE
BROADLY THERE'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE
CONCERN THAT- AGAIN WHEN THIS IS
JUST SORT OF UP TO A DOZEN CALL
FROM THE BOARDS THERE COULD BE
AT A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE RATHER
THAN HAVING A SORT OF NEUTRAL-
HALL WITH THE BAR SOMEWHERE ELSE
IN THE BUILDING YOU KNOW IT
MOVES CLOSER TO BEING DIRECTLY
IN A PLACE WITH COVERED IN SIGNS
COVERED AND- CUPBOARD AN
ADVERTISING WITH. CAPS THERE
SMELLING OF ALCOHOL STUFF THAT
CAN BE DEEPLY TRIGGERING TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
PROBLEMS ALCOHOL- YOU KNOW AGAIN
AND AGAIN SIR SECONDARILY THAT
THAT ADVERTISING IS AN ISSUE.
WONDER IF- AN ELECTION IN WHICH
ALCOHOL POLICY IS SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN PUT FOR THEM THE VOTERS-
WOULD THIS BE. PARTICULARLY IN
POINTING ON THEIR VOTE YOU KNOW
THAT SORT OF THE EXAMPLE I GO TO
IS THE FOR PROFIT TWENTY TWO.
DOUBLE YEARS GUYS YOU WOULD HAVE
I MEAN IF YOU WANT TO WRAP UP
YOU PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE. AND
WE RECOGNIZE AGAINST THE AUTHORS
HAVE EXPRESSED AN INTENTION KEEP
WORKING ON THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
BILL WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT BUT
ASKED STANDS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
TO STAND IN OPPOSITION. AND I
THINK SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WILL NOT MOVE
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC
WHAT FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL.
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
ALL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL WILL START IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM. WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE
WILL NOW OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR- AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND AS
A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TWO ARE. RIGHT YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. MISTER
CHAIR WE'RE GETTING NOBODY TO
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH- ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLOOR YOU MAY CLOSE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. WE HAVE
A MOTION TO MOVE BY. MAYES
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
THIS BILL HAS IT DO PASS
REFERRAL FROM THE CHAIR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M AT TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY
FLORA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION BRIAN.
BRIAN I SEYARTO SEYARTO I
BANDIT. BANDIT I LO. LO I MAYES
MAYES I MULLIN. MULLIN I BLANCA
RUBIO I WANT TO RUBIO I. THAT'S
UNANIMOUS VOTE YOU'RE OUT THANK
SIR IT'S THE SHOES MEN'S SHOES.
THE FINAL ITEM ON THE AGENDA
TODAY IS AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EVAN LOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN YOU READY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DON'T HAVE
AS GOOD A SHOES BUT HAPPY TO BE
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN I AM EXCITED TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE AN INTRODUCED
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SEEN THIS.
PROPOSAL A NUMBER OF TIMES
BEFORE BUT WE ARE ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND
VOTING RIGHTS FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS AND WITH ME I HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES FOR THIS BILL
THE FIRST PRIMARY WITNESSES.
CHRISTOPHER MAHER WITH ASK ME.
YEAH GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE GREAT STRIDES TO ENSURE
THAT VOTERS HAVE TIME AND
FLEXIBILITY. IN THE VOTING
PROCESS TO SAFEGUARD AGAINST
VOTER SUPPRESSION TECHNIQUES
ROOTED IN RACISM AND CLASSISM.
AND TO ENSURE THAT VOTING IN
CALIFORNIA IS A RIGHT NOT A
PRIVILEGE. STILL THE LEGISLATURE
HAS NOT TAKEN THE STEP TO
DESIGNATE ELECTION DAY STATEWIDE
HOLIDAY AND ELEVATE THE DAY TO
THE STATURE IT DESERVES. WE HAVE
NUMEROUS DAYS TO REMEMBER EVENTS
LONG PAST INTO REMEMBER
IMPORTANT FIGURES WHO HAVE
SHAPED OUR SOCIETY. SOME OF THE
HOLIDAYS WE OBSERVE ARE
INHERENTLY PROBLEMATIC BUT WE
DON'T PLACE THE SAME IMPORTANCE
ON THE DAY THAT KEEPS US MOVING
FORWARD. BUT IT ISN'T JUST ABOUT
THE SYMBOLISM DECLARING ELECTION
DAY STATEWIDE HOLIDAY WILL
ENABLE STUDENTS AND WORKERS TO
VOLUNTEER IN THE ELECTION
PROCESS. IT WILL ENCOURAGE MORE
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO FOLLOW SUIT
AS THEY HAVE WITH OTHER
HOLIDAYS. AND IT WILL INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT
AND ABOUT CHATTING IN PUBLIC AND
WEARING THEIR I VOTED STICKERS
THOSE OF YOU HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN VOTER OUTREACH DRIVES. NO
THAT PEER PRESSURE IS ONE OF THE
BEST TOOLS TO GET SOMEONE TO
VOTE. MOST IMPORTANTLY PROVIDING
THAT THEY OFFER BUSY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WILL ENCOURAGE THEM TO
DEVELOP A LIFELONG HABIT. AT A
CRUCIAL TIME IN THEIR LIVES. BUT
IT'S JOIN COUNTLESS OTHER STATES
COUNTRIES AND CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES THAT HAVE DECLARED
SPECIFIC SECOND SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE DAY THAT WE ABOUT.
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK RE TESTIMONY ARE
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESSES ALVIN
LEE WOULD CHEN UP WHO WAS ON THE
PHONE MISTER LEE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARED MANY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ALVIN B. OF RECENT BAY
AREA PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE
CURRENT COLLEGE FRESHMAN AND A
MEMBER OF CHEN UP CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST USE THAT EDUCATION
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION. WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORED AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TO. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
IS UNDOUBTEDLY A MONUMENTAL
BUILDING CALIFORNIA. MOVING AT
THE FOREMOST AVENUE FOR
CONSTITUENTS DIRECTLY EXERCISE
THE DEMOCRATIC RIGHTS THIS BILL
FACILITATES BUILDING BILLION
SUPPORT WITH PEOPLE. ALEXION
HELD ON TUESDAYS DURING THE WORK
DAY RESULT WITH LESS PEOPLE
GOING TO THE POLLS DESPITE THE
TO ABSENTEE VOTING. TURNING
ELECTION DAY INTO STATEWIDE
HOLIDAY WOULD TURN VOTING INTO A
CELEBRATION OF DEMOCRACY. BY
CLOSING PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR THE
DAY NOT ONLY WILL TEACHERS TAP.
INTO THE BETTER CHANCE OF
PASSING POLITICS BUT MORE SCHOOL
COULD BE USED AS POLLING
LOCATIONS. FURTHERMORE THIS
MAKES IT EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO
VOLUNTEER GET OUT THE VOTE IN
THIS POLL WORKERS. ESTABLISHING
ELECTION DAY OF THE HOLIDAY
WOULD OPEN UP SCHOOLS POSSIBLE
POLLING. LOCATIONS THE PAYS
REPRESENTS THE ACTIVE VOTING
ALLOWING PARENTS BRING THEIR
CHILDREN TO THE- MOST. WITNESS
COMPARATIVO EXERCISING ARGUABLY
DID BACK. I BET TWENTY TWENTY
PHONE BANKING TEXAS BANKING AND
DEDUCTIBLES THE GENERAL
ELECTIONS. THE BILL WOULD MAKE
IT. EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO
VOLUNTEER AT THE PUMP WASH THE
QUEEN CAGED POPULAR CULTURE AND
A GENERATION OF CONSISTENT AND
SMART BURGERS. I VERY RECENTLY
JUST BECAUSE THE OLD ENOUGH TO
VOTE CASTING A FIRST EVER VOTE
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. GOOD
NEWS FOR YOU. I FULFILL OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT WILL DO
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO ENSURE THE
IS SIMPLE AN EXTRA FOR YOU I
RESPECTFUL ASK. FOR THE AYE.
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER LEE A NEW BUT AND-
CITIZEN OUGHT TO GET THANK YOU
ENJOY US TODAY WE HAVE NO. WITH
AND UP TO THIS. WILL MOVE AHEAD
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. AND OF
OPPOSITION IN THIS BILL. FOR THE
PUBLIC OF REMINDER WITH FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME. FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE LIMITED
TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL WILL START IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM. WHO WISHES TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION ON A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. SEEING NONE WE WILL
NOW OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
DIGITAL TESTIMONY ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO MODERATED
WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE. WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS-
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
LINE TWENTY ONE. YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ERIC HARRIS SOME WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY TWO
. THANK YOU MISTER. I WILL GO
ONLINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. AND WOOD
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS
SANTIAGO CALIFORNIAN BY MENTAL
VOTERS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU
SANTIAGO. AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
EXPRESS- OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
FOR A BI EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
AND LINE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
PETER WARDELL WITH LIKE- THE
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE OPPOSED AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO. AND ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ONE
QUEUING UP FOR ANYBODY ELSE AGO
IT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME SO THE
OPERATOR CAN. GIVE YOU- YOUR
LINE NUMBER IN LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE TO GET
ANYMORE YOUNG WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THE STRUCTURE
THAT DOES THE EXACT SECURE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. MISTER MASON. TELLS A BUMMER
BECAUSE I HAVE A GREAT AFFECTION
FOR THE AUTHOR OF AN INVINCIBLE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MANY OF HIS
BILLS- BUT ONCE AGAIN I'LL BE
VOTING NO ON THIS ON THIS
MEASURE- THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS-
THAT I HAVE- BEEN A RABID
SUPPORTER OF MAIL IN BALLOTS
BECAUSE- I BELIEVE ACCESS VOTING
RIGHTS AND GETTING IN THE HANDS
OF VOTERS MAKING AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO VOTE IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
YOU GET THAT BALLOT ALMOST FOUR
WEEKS BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON AT
ALL TO BE ABLE HAVE A STATE
HOLIDAY IT'S A WASTE OF
RESOURCES AND FOR THAT REASON- I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS AT
THIS BILL. TODAY THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES BUT YOURSELF. ALL
RIGHT SO I'M GOING TO PAY YOU
BACK A I AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
ALREADY PREVIOUSLY MADE. FOR
CALLING FROM THE YUCCA VALLEY-
GIVEN OUR CURRENT ELECTION LAWS.
IT'S REALLY NOT NEEDED- THE FOUR
DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION DAY THE
PEOPLE CAN VOTE IN PERSON- GIVES
THEM A WEEKEND SATURDAY SUNDAY
MONDAY AND TUESDAY. SO THAT THEY
CAN GO IN- MOST PEOPL-
ESPECIALLY IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
ALREADY OFF. ON SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY. AND THEN MOST PEOPLE ARE
OFF ON SUNDAYS. SO THAT ALLOWS
THE PRIVATE PUBLIC PRIVATE
SECTOR AND THE PUBLIC SECTOR TO
BE TREATED EQUALLY- THIS WOULD
SET UP A SITUATION WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. PEOPLE NOT BEING
ABLE TO GO TO THE POLLS MOST
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES ARE
ACTUALLY NOT THE PEOPLE THAT.
SHOULD BE THIS SHOULD BE AIMED
AT- BECAUSE THEIR THEIR JOBS ARE
INHERENTLY BETTER JOBS AND
BETTER PAID AND THEY ALSO HAVE
GOOD BENEFITS. IT WHICH INCLUDES
TIME OFF TO GO VOTE ON ELECTION
DAY IF WE IF NEED BE. I USED TO
HAVE TO MANAGE THIS MYSELF- BY
YOU KNOW WITH A WHOLE BATTALION
OF FOLKS THAT WANT TO VOTE. BUT
THE ADVENT OF MAIL IN BALLOTS TO
COME OUT A MONTH AHEAD OF TIME
IT'S REALLY NOT NEEDED. THE
OTHER CONCERN I HAVE IS THIS- I
ALSO- AND- VERY SENSITIVE TO.
THAT FEBRUARY HOLIDAY THAT'S
PRESIDENT'S DAY WEEKEND IT'S
USUALLY A FOUR DAY HOLIDAY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG HOLIDAYS
THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GET
THEIR KIDS TAKE A BREAK FROM
SCHOOL AND GET OUT OF TOWN. AND
THAT'S ALSO A WINTER HOLIDAY SO
EXPAND SOME OF THE THAT THINGS
THAT THEY GET TO DO- IN THAT
TIME AND IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY
FOR THE HOLIDAYS- BREAKING THAT
UP AND NOT LETTING THEM DO THAT
EVERY SECOND YEAR- I THINK IT.
IS TOO MUCH OF A TRADE OFF. TO
GAIN WHAT I THINK IS NOT REALLY
MUCH FROM THIS IF YOU HAD
BROUGHT THIS WHEN WE DID NOT
HAVE OUR CURRENT LAWS. SET UP
FOR A GROUP A FOR MAILING
VOTING. PRIVATE PROBABLY BE OKAY
WITH IT- BUT SINCE IT IT DIVIDES
THE PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. IT TAKES AWAY THAT
HOLIDAY THAT IS VALUABLE TO
FAMILIES AND- IN IT'S JUST NOT
NEEDED- I'LL ALSO BE VOTING NO.
THANKS ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I SURE THE
AUTHORS GOALS OF REDUCING
BARRIERS TO VOTING- I AM
CONCERNED THAT PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
HAVE WON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE STATES LEAD ON
CALIFORNIA'S TAKE A LOT OF STEPS
RECENTLY VOTE BY MAIL EXPANSION
EXPANDING THE WINDOW TO VOTING
BUT I THINK A LOT OF THOSE
EFFORTS MAKING ELECTION DAY A
HOLIDAY AS ANOTHER TOOL TOWARD
REDUCING THOSE BARRIERS AND SO
I'M RECOMMENDING. AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL MADAM SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL- IS THERE A MOTION
TO MOVE THE BILL. MOVED BY SOME
MEMBER MULLIN SECONDED BY
SOMEONE OF A RUBIO. CAN CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BY SEVEN MEMBER LOW
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION BRIAN
R. BRIAN I SEYARTO NO SEYARTO NO
BENNETT. BENNETT I KNOW I LOW I
NEED. AS KNOWN MULLIN. MOMENT
AYE BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I
. THE BILL IS OUT. FIVE TO
PROTECT RESTORE. PREHISTORICAL
PHILLAURI CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL
ON FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON. FIFTY
AT THE- END OF. I THINK THIS IS
ON AB TWENTY THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA THE
MOTION TO PASS AND BE REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MULLIN MULLIN I. THE ITEM THIS.
I AM FOR IS ON ON CONSENT FOR
CONSENT CALENDAR AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BRIAN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CONSENT CALENDAR LOW
. LOW I MULLIN. MULLIN I. I
SPOKE WITH LOW FEDERAL WITH THAT
THIS MEETING IS A JERK THANK YOU
THAT'S ALL. IT WOULD BE MORE
PROCESS IS FROM. 50% OF PATIENT
IS THAT IT WILL BE FEW MINUTES
LOBBYIST BUT. IT'S KIND FOR
REPUBLICANS PERHAPS CAN KEEP THE
PRESSURE ON FROM HERE I THINK SO
WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU. YEAH WE
MOVING.